I'm Andrew lines
thank you good evening everybody and
welcome to this extraordinary meeting of
the Council on Thursday the 8th of June
2023 my name is councilor Kevin Lagan
and I'm the chairperson of the Malden
District Council just a few housekeeping
issues to run through first members
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and burn being present
at the meeting you're giving your
consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I'll
then invite you at the appropriate time
could I ask members to avoid approaching
the top table as this could create
interference with the cameras and live
stream we had some problems last time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn off your microphone and
turn it off when turn it on and then
turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible I've just
recovered from an illness so I'll be a
bit breathless so excuse me if I cough
and I may have to call for a German if
that effect if that kicks in and it's
not covered I can confirm that I've also
again I'm suspending uh rule 4 rule 8
subsection three of the Constitution of
the requirement for standing when
addressing the chair that will be
optional this evening except for a
gender item 12 when I've got to ask
members to stand when we nominate
committees
okay we move on to agenda item two which
is the appointment of Vice chairperson
accounts a stamp please
thank you chairman
um I would like to nominate for purely
for balance and not having a pure top
table of males which it looks like it
could be
um I would like to nominate and propose
counselor Jeanette still so I understand
that she's worked closely with you she
has been previous mayor at Malden Town
Council and I think she's done
exceptionally well and I think she
should be
um put forward to be the vice chair of
this Council and do I have a seconder
please
I think you should be diverse it tastes
diverse thank you do have a second do I
cancel fluka so Council flew to Second
there
yep accounts uh um stamp thank you for
that nomination I have to just actually
make the call for the um Vice
chairperson first
um but then you've made your points
clear so I'll then allow that to happen
after I actually called for it so a call
for the nominations for vice chairman of
the council for the next Municipal year
nominations Mr chairman I nominate the
councilor Ron Pratt seconded
and a second it was that seconded by
councilor siddle members any other
members nominate
okay members what this means that we
need to vote
uh pardon me yeah can we have recorded
vote please is that seconded yeah second
is recorded vote request is seconded by
councilor fluka
so the first uh member that was put
forward was counselor Jeanette stilts so
we'll need members to to call offer
recorded vote satara
have you got the role
uh they're normally in a recorded vote
is each individual member that's called
or individually thank you accounts are
still starting to please
uh no
Dane
cancel the phone hello
councilor Burwood and abstain count the
driver abstain
okay
or cancer
Council Hughes
no but we never got cancer that Hayward
Tara sorry
abstain
[Music]
no
four
against
not dispensely
oh sorry
[Laughter]
I can't believe
abstain
[Laughter]
so I wish you could work first
time thank you I mean Cancer Paula
Spencer
episode thank you Council Stone
not wasting a vote for
[Music]
against thank you cancer still
there's too many microphones on at the
very back that's it thank you
Council Swindle abstain
against
the same please Tara
the results of that are five four eleven
against and eleven staining chairman
thank you so now we call for the uh
nomination of councilor Pratt so again
uh recorder vote's been called for so
again could we please uh I go through
the role please Tara
four
abstain
oh
cancer
fluka
against councilor Heywood
thanks
cancer Hughes four
Jennings abstain abstain
before
Captain dinner
four
deal against Council Pratt
Paul
abstain
I'm stuck
against
four
cancer stilts against
abstain
for
abstained Easter
thank you chairman the results of that
are thirteen four or five against and
nine abstaining thank you Tara thank you
members there for uh declare that
councilor Pratt is duly uh named as the
vice chairman of the Malden District
Council and I invite councilor Pratt to
undertake the statutory declaration
office please
thank you members
um
I I Ronald George Pratt
having been elected to the office of
Vice chairperson of the Council of the
District of Malden declare that I take
the office upon myself
or Julian Faithfully fulfill the duties
of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability I undertake to
observe the code as to the conduct which
is expected of members of modern
District Council
thank you very much and pass it to the
monitoring officer
thank you
very much and I very much look forward
to seeing you in the fourth coming weeks
undertake your Civic responsibilities
thank you thank you members we now move
on to agenda item number four which is
apologies for absence Tara have any
apologies please
thank you very much indeed
item number five sorry Council stamp
Grandma you just say people would look
around for people if they've got their
hand up that's correct and counselor una
Norman Center apologist chairman thank
you very much indeed
we move on to agenda item five which is
disclosure of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-registerable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware
should the knees arise throughout the
meeting remember do I have any interest
counselor Darren please
thank you very much chairman um I do
have uh interest in relation to motion
two
um in respect of the Devolution working
group because I am the deputy Cabinet
member for Devolution the Arts and
Heritage at Essex County Council
thank you
any other members
can I just need to to speak to the
monetary office just a moment members so
I might be a second
um
thank you members thank you patience
Council down could I ask you what your
interest is please
and why you declared the interest
but well it's non-pecuniary it's um just
to openness and transparency in what
respect
non-registerable registerable
I seek guidance from the monitoring
officer I mean
it's the quelch
that non-pecuniary doesn't exist
um we there's three there's um this goes
all pecuniary interest there's other
registerable interests and there's an
honorable interest I think it's an other
registerable interest at the register
interest okay
yeah and obviously members need to just
for clarification if I made chairman if
there's another registerable interest
members have to go through in their own
minds obviously not out loud but in
their minds whether it directly affects
um the um
registerable interest in this case Essex
County Council
um and if it does then of course members
need to leave the chamber
uh or if it only affects
they then need to go through the
two-pronged test that I've mentioned in
the training
um and namely is
would this interest affect
uh
would this interest have more effect
than the majority and obviously it would
then the second more important question
here is would Joe public think the
reasonable man in the street knowing all
the facts that that this interest could
affect your view of the wider public
interest so that that's obviously a
matter for each member to to to work out
in their own minds because if you decide
um yes to one of those two questions
then you need to leave the room
I I think on that advice I will leave
the room for the sake of any confusion
although I'm not a decision maker in
that process
thank you Mr quotes thank you councilor
I respect that
we move on to item number six which is
public questions there are none uh
chairpersons announcements is item
number seven I have none we move on to
agenda item eight which is notices of
motions in accordance with notice Julie
given under procedural rule four
councilor a.s fluca to move the
following motions Julie secondary by
councilors W stamp and councilor Jay
stilts councilor Fluker
yeah thank you chairman I I Rise to
present my emotions to Chairman I won't
read the Motions they're contained
within the uh within the minute they're
within the agenda items and foreign
plan review working group meetings uh
resume immediately and that all members
were appointed to the working group it's
then it's anticipated that members of
the working group at the council will be
appointed at the meeting the council
tonight it's noted that the critical
local development plan review working
group meeting which was due to consider
the highly controversial subject of
growth options which affects the whole
district has now been postponed to early
July this means the working group won't
have met for nearly two months the time
currently Allowed by the conservative
government for local authorities to
review their plans is very short and if
missed the government's default Position
will apply and our opportunity to shape
District through the revision of our
local plan will be lost for that reason
meetings of this working group should
resume immediately and without further
delay the local plan review affects all
Ward members particularly so with
regards to growth options and that said
all members all members should be given
the opportunity to comment at the
earliest possible opportunity and be
part of this working group it is
accepted that members can attend working
group meetings but by making the working
group all member it is hoped that there
will be more commitment and
understanding for more members which
should mean a faster Passage through the
Committees and that as a result the
government's statutory time landline
could actually be achieved and chairman
I know you're probably anxious for me to
finish but just for the benefit of the
new members when we have working groups
they often come back to committee they
go back to the working group other
members come along and impact things and
it slows the whole process down I bought
this forward chairman in the basis that
it's in the best interest of the council
and that we are all involved so chairman
I conclude by saying I so move thank you
thank you you said that seconded um
Council privilege I'll open the floor
and debate for this first motion members
well thank you very much uh chairman yes
it is very important but due to the
current review of the mppf I was looking
for the number of councils that have
suspended their local plan review
because it is in excess of 20 local
authorities in England have suspended
their plan reviews
I mean we're debating a procedure all
for
um chairman we're actually debating
determine whether or not to have an
all-member working group not the
mechanics about the mpps in fact what's
been said actually gives us even more
weight to do this thank you
okay
well it was a point of information
Germans I think you put your point of
information around the point of order
thank you any other members wish to
speak
members we Kazakhstan thank you thank
you chairman
um it is for the benefit of the new
members
um I think last year this working group
didn't meet for a few months when they
were applying for is it you that funding
can you remember can anybody help me out
when they the the offices were taken off
to do the ukip funding is it German
um Mr Dodson
defending I believe you mean the
leveling up fans I knew it was something
chairman I think it's important that
members
members we have we had it last year so
we're already behind schedule and you
should have received the updates and the
information from um the officer anyway
so I totally support that we need to get
this ldp up and running this Council
what councilor Durham said we haven't
agreed to suspend it in fact I think the
opposite I thought we were looking at
actually pulling a a fast one and moving
it on so I would actually urge that you
do take this Motion in the spirit it's
meant and that we start cracking on with
what we're elected to do which is the
spatial objectives and we do our own
planning and we don't leave it to
speculative developers thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much councilor
snap any other member
cassador I can just come back and read
you uh so far 11 authorities have paused
or delayed work on their local plans
this year this year alone 2023 six of
which explicitly cited the government's
proposed changes to National planning
policy as the reason for their delay
important information thank you very
much and very informative okay members
um we have a motion it has been seconded
sorry cancel the stand yes
um could I actually ask then in all
fairness for everybody's sake can we
have some advice from the directors
about well are we thinking about
stopping this this plan how can we how
can we actually go on for on what Mr Mr
Mr Mr Durham said without some advice
from somebody no as I understand it
Council of Luke and I'll refer to the
directors in a moment and I wish I could
be wrong is that we are actually
progressing
yes
thank you chairman
um the advice consistently from from our
planning officers has been that we
should continue and that the plan can be
adapted to the changes to the mppf
however there are
the changes aren't entirely clear yet in
terms of the mppf changes because there
are consultations going on but at the
moment I see no no reason that we would
suspend it and that we'd continue
working
um with a view to adapting it to to any
changes that there should be in duke or
I think if it doesn't count so they're
fluke of your rights yeah thank you um
chairman I mean I think in summary I
think I think members are certainly more
informed now because look I do know that
some planning authorities
um have ceased this work but we are
quite some way into it we're further
into it than these these other local
authorities and if we keep going we can
actually get our review done
and we will get a plan which is going to
protect this district from speculative
development but to do that we've all got
to be involved in I and I think that
what counselor
what counts the stamps is is that's the
hair moment it's done on purpose
um what counselor Stampy says is
absolutely right she wants more
information we all want more information
and this is why I'm saying we should all
be on this working group if we're all on
the working group we can all step in and
out we can get the information we want
we can understand what's going on
specifically from our Wards and not
leave it for you know the eight or ten
people that are on this working group I
mean during the last Administration I
think I I I I think the uh the leader
electors are on the work we used to
despair it together that how few people
um uh turned up at the meetings we all
need to get behind this it's for the
benefit of this District so Tim
um I've moved my motion chairman and I
hope that everybody supports it thank
you councilor fluke um I now move the
motion which cancel the flux moves to
the vote and for those in favor of
councilor flutes motion number one uh
please raise your hand
record a vote okay it's been called
recorded vote seconded so recorded vote
by councilor stamp second by councilor
fluka Tara could you take the the role
please
against
four
I'm staying
[Music]
abstain
against
upstate
four
against
abstain
full
against
four
stain
against
four please time
thank you very much sorry that motion
Falls I mean never move on to motion to
um cassadoran's disagree to leave the
chamber thank you councilor Durham
thank you
okay councilor would you like to present
motion two yeah thank you very much
um chairman um so motion two chairman
that regardless of the paralysis the
council Council agrees to form a
Devolution working group and that all
members of the council are appointed to
the group whose first meeting should
take place no longer than 14 days from
agreeing this motion
um chairman it's anticipating that
members of the working groups of council
will be appointed tonight and that the
formation of a new Evolution working
group may be agreed in advance to that
being considered this motion gives the
opportunity for all members to be
involved it in what is likely to be the
dissolution of modern District Council
in its current format
including the possible transfers of
assets including Promenade Park
Riverside Park height and Princess Road
campus to a new greater Essex Authority
a senior well-informed and well-placed
member of this Council has stated that
in advance of the likely dissolution of
this Council
a greater Essex ghost Council will be
set up in 2025 which will be led by an
electric mayor whose statutory powers in
some areas may be soldering to those
currently enjoyed by this Council this
would be followed in 2027 with elections
to a new greater Essex wild Authority it
is noted that the Devolution process has
been driven by a six County Council and
that the deputy Cabinet member
responsible for this process bringing
this process forward is a member of this
District Council is therefore for
members to decide whether there is a
conflict of interest and how that could
affect appointments committees and
working
due to the lack of meaningful briefings
by the former leader some members of the
previous administration were left
disenfranchised and uninformed the
uncertainty or lack of information
surrounded the formation of a greater
Essex Authority also affects our
residence businesses and customers for
those reasons it's very important that
the Devolution working group meets as a
matter of urgency and that all members
of this the council are appointed to the
working group basically over the last
year there has been rumor there's been
conjecture there's been all sorts of
things said to members and we have not
had uh full updates and this is very
very important when you start looking at
the assets of this country the assets of
this Council how they are going to be
affected and and I guess that officers
May well come up with a with a different
take on what I've just said this is the
problem there is no there is no hard and
fast information going back to to
members and and as I say these the
greater Essex Authority could see the
dissolution of this Council in its
current format so
I hope members will support this and I
hope members vote either way because I
think I don't actually think we're
elected here
um to abstain we should vote so chairman
I move motion two thank you thank you
very much indeed councilor fluke before
I move to the members um I'll just asked
Mr Dodson to address this please
thank you chairman I just wanted to
clarify some of the briefings that were
issued
um during the last 12 months well these
discussions have been going on and there
were arrangements made for all not all
not just all members of this Council but
all members of all councils across the
the county to be briefed and there were
two briefings arranged
um face to face and there were the the
previous leader did circulate
information from the the leaders and
chief Executives meetings also
members were informed when the
expression of interest that went in from
the County Council South End and
thurrock councils that was published and
is available on the County Council
website as of of March
um all of that is in line with the white
paper on Devolution that was published
last year
um and there is safeguards within that
that there is no
Devolution upwards of sovereignty of
this Council within that or District
councils the Devolution is from
government to those upper tier
authorities and a combined Authority
which would be formed under a level
three deal
would be made up of those three councils
there is a discussion of whether the
districts would be party to the
governance of that but again that would
be based on downward Devolution from
government so that those are the the
facts that we know from the white paper
and also from the the bid that's gone in
there was also a further brief in this
this morning at the leaders and chief
Executives meeting which I attended
um as we don't yet have a leader of the
council
there's a from that briefing that went
to leaders there will be which I'll
obviously share with the leader of the
council when they are elected there's
also a brief in that is being compiled
by the um that group
to go again to every member of every
Council within the county of all of the
the districts so
respect counts counselor fluka and and
what he had to say but I thought it's
important just to to clarify from from
an officer perspective thank you
chairman for the opportunity thank you
Mr Dodson remember just before I move to
the the chamber could I just ask
everybody to put their Mobile phones on
the silent please I've got counselor
Castle stamp thank you very much
okay remove councilor white please
um thank you Mr chairman for allowing me
to speak
um yeah I I actually attended
um as chair of stretching resources all
of these Devolution meetings and I
actually raised in one of them about is
this about losing Malden District
Council
and there was a bit of a fabrication by
officers but another member said to me
in a message system actually yes that is
going to happen
so this is vitally important that we
have a group for this to Evolution
because this affects every single one of
us and every single one of our residents
and it's something that we must be
involved with members and my other
concern is our MP has concerns with
Devolution and he is our elected MP and
this is something that we must stand up
and be counted for
I also
um have issues with giving one man more
power than all the MPS we currently have
in Essex this one man will be able to
make decisions for the whole County
and for me do we want to give one man
that word we need this working group and
we actually need to stand up for what we
believe in we need to stand up for our
residents it's our duty to stand up for
them thank you for letting me speak
thank you Council the white Council
stamp please mine's on your quick
question you'd be pleased to know when
were you when you when Mr Dodson briefs
the new leader whoever that may be how
long will it take to come to the council
because I whilst I take on board some of
the comments that you made you said I I
don't agree that we were briefed as
counselors enough of what we should have
been
um I'm I'm
double-hearted I'm an Essex County
councilor but I do not ever and I've
spoken to the monitor officer disclose
anything that I get told at Essex so
I've got no conflict of interest here
about Devolution but what I am concerned
about is that we're not given the
information quick enough and the
actualness so the whole truth of what
possibly is being said and I think
whoever the leader is going to be I
would urge them to actually share it and
don't keep it secret from the rest of
the members and I'm going to back
totally what councilor white and
councilor um fluke has said and I hope
members who obviously
have been whipped to abstain chooses not
to be wit and well I'm sorry report me
to the monitoring officer who's sitting
there we're elected to vote on important
issues and we need to vote on important
issues you as elected to vote on thank
you chairman thank you Council stamp any
other member wish to speak on the
accounts the steals please
thank you Mr chairman chairman I'd like
to also back what council of Luke and
councilor white has said I have actually
been told that we're ready to go to
consultation for an elected mayor so
um they are expecting to put elected
mayor in by 2025 so I will back also
what councilor fluka
okay thank you counselors any other
member of cancer
yeah I just figured out agenda items
16.3.7 says the following working group
is related to list Devolution working
groups so have we already got a working
group being proposed the working group
has a thank you counselor fitted the
working group has been proposed but this
is this is the whole Council so where it
says Devolution working group that all
members of the council so it's a
separate Motion in its own right
although you are quite correct there is
a Devolution working group coming
forward later on on the agenda
okay any other member wish to speak
okay we need to put this to the vote
members please uh so sum up again sorry
um yeah just for the benefit of Council
of fit talk and others um I did send out
the Preamble today and and I did make it
quite clear in the in paragraph one
um that we were due to consider this uh
then decide whether or not we should
have a Devolution working group this
evening and and that there's a small
number of members that have been
appointed to that working group
um I'm even more I'm even more
confused now
um I I mean I'm grateful for the
comments of Mr Dodson who I know has
attended a lot of these meetings and and
I I accept what he says
um but he also did use in relation to
one of his comments whether or not the
district would be affected now the
problem we have is there is too much
information going around we know we have
the white paper which speaks to Mayors
and it speaks to funding so we know that
sits there and then after that it's just
been a case of Essex County Council
leading on this to form this greater
Essex Authority
um
if a if a member of Essex County Council
says that we're going to have a ghost
Authority in effectively 23 months time
and and a mayor then
I'm absolutely staggered that that's not
been reported to us and and and I mean I
don't know if Mr Dodson can speak to
that or not but I'm judging by his face
and I've looked at his face for a number
of years I think he's surprised as me
but this is what the problem is with
this we've got a tiny little working
group of members that are going to be
looking at the evolution reporting back
to the council and I think it is such a
big thing I think it is such a big thing
we should have a bigger working group
I'd prefer to have all members involved
in this working group so chairman
um
I'm not sure I moved this motion but
chairman for clarity
um I move uh motion two thank you
thank you very much indeed
thank you Council and stem Mr Dodson
please yes if I could just clarify that
I did say that with a level three
Devolution deal there would be a mayoral
combined Authority
and there would be a full public
consultation on that ahead of that but
that would sit above the three upper
tier authorities and wouldn't directly
affect the governance of Malden District
Council under the proposals that have
been put forward
I don't think it's I don't think we're
concerned about governance it's a matter
of what's left and I think that's what
we really need to find out what's going
on because there seems to be conflicting
views everywhere
um look councilor diamond isn't in the
chamber and it was right for him to
leave but you know comments have been
made and it concerns me that maybe some
of those comments have come from Essex
County Council and they've not been made
privy yet to the officers of this
Council or indeed members thank you
thank you very much okay I think we've
debated this enough members that need to
take this to the vote please so uh do
you show this by sending
recorded vote requested by councilor
Fluker seconded by councilor stamp Tara
please again it's for or against members
please devotion
[Music]
or staying
against
cancer
abstain
against
the Shaughnessy against Council against
friends against
four cancer Stephen
against
four
that's a swindle against okay
against
actually I'm going to vote for this one
because I think Devo is really important
thank you members that motion Falls uh
councilor fluka um
I think the uh the public again in a
good idea of voting preferences no just
wait till cancel
I'll have to repeat that again
foreign
motion three is very straightforward
um chairman this is that the director of
strategy performance and governance uh
Mr Dodson provides without exception
updates regarding Essex wide Devolution
to all future meetings of council
um chairman if agreed it will ensure
that all members residents local
businesses and our customers and we must
never forget our customers we'll receive
regular updates on the Devolution
process including the formation of the
greater Essex Authority and the impacts
of doing this on this Council chairman
ISO move thank you thank you councilor
fluka members
second thank you very much indeed
anybody wish to speak on this
okay would you like to sum up there's
not much I rather hope that the members
think if nothing else this is a good
idea and we can get these updates and
and we can rely I know we can rely on Mr
Dodson to give us clear accurate and
succinct updates and and hopefully the
opportunity at that time to ask
questions so chairman I've moved the
motion thank you thank you very much
indeed councilor Luca uh members we need
to put this to the vote is
did I hear recorded vote recorded vote
requested by cancer Fluker seconded by
Council stamp and Tara could you please
take the role for against or abstain
please members
[Music]
against
four
[Music]
for cancer Hayward for capsa Hughes four
four
[Music]
Council Miller against Captain Morgan
against
for
eign
against
for
four show me the results are about our
17 for 10 against the extension thank
you very much Sarah that motion passes
thank you very much indeed thank you
members for that we now move on to
agenda item nine oh this is questions in
accordance with procedural six two of
which notices have been given and there
are none
we move on to agenda item 10 which is
leaders and composition of political
groups
um this is uh gender item 10. there was
a supplementary pack which was
circulated today and the information can
be found on pages three and four and I
call on Mr Dodson to present the report
please
thank you chairman
um this is straightforward report really
it clarifies the the political groupings
um of the council
and requests that the the council
appoints a leader and a deputy leader of
the council voting first on the the
leader designer thank you chairman thank
you very much indeed Mr Dodson they we
have recommendations the recommendations
are little one that the council
considers ratification of the leader
designate as leader of the council and
recommendation number two that the
council elects the deputy leader of the
council I move a recommendation one set
out in the report that the council
considers ratification of the leader
designate counselor SJ in Norman as
leader of the council Mr Mr chairman I
resolves
leader designate and do not wish to put
myself forward for that okay
so
we would then there move for nominations
I believe Mr Welch
that counts the stamp please
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
nominate councilor Sue White to be the
leader of this Authority Sue worked very
closely with some of us in the early
stages and was very helpful conciliatory
and I think would have put a excellent
leadership team together and I would
invite that I have a second of a council
of white to be put as the leader of this
Council and I'll ask for a recorded vote
please thank you so if councilor white
and councilor for second to that
councilor White
thank you Mr chairman um I have to say
this has been a bit of a surprise to me
to put it pretty mildly
um because I've done no deals no horse
trading no nothing I've not spoken to
anybody other in the first week so I'm
I'm feeling a bit peculiar to be honest
but on the other hand although it will
fail and I won't succeed I will keep my
head above the parapet as I have done in
all the elections and um as I say it it
won't happen because I've done no deals
but on the other hand after the shocks
worn off
um you know if we don't put our head up
every now and again where are we
yeah so the White House the passenger
I'd like to nominate Mr Richard siddle
please yeah it's the serial nominator
seconder please
that was close so I was there so that
was councilor fittich any other members
wish to nominate
no so again we we come to a position
where we have two nominees for the
position of leader of the council
um so therefore we need to go through
and vote
um do you wish to have a record to vote
on this Council stamp yeah you did
indeed and Council the flu probably
second of that so if councilor white was
called first sorry councilor Durham
please well can I suggest rather than
that we just give the surname of the
person as it goes around the the room
whether that's I think that's a noble
way of doing it I think with consistency
we need to stay with how we've been
doing it all okay
thank you very much indeed councilor
Darren for that so councilor white was
nominated first so we'll take the vote
for councilor white first Tara could you
please
take the role
as big as a council
Passenger please against
about against
[Music]
Council Drive
against
or
hello against
[Music]
I've seen
abstain
against
perhaps an expensive against
oh
thank you very much Tara we now move to
the nomination of council Richard siddle
so again Tara if you could be kind
enough to take the role it's for against
or abstain please
four
[Music]
against
four
Morgan abstain
against
abstain
for
three four
hundred percent against
a hundred percent four
against
four
stain pumps are white against
thank you very much I therefore declare
that Council Richard is the leader of
golden District Council
thank councilor Morgan thank you very
much
members please
thank you
members just before I move on to uh
recommendation two which is to elect a
deputy leader of the council and call
for nominations I just wonder if the
leader has anything he wishes to say by
this stage thank you very much members
therefore we move on to nominations to
elect a deputy leader of the council and
I do therefore call for nomination
nominate Mark councilor Bassinger
members any other nominations
can I propose um
councilor stamp thank you Jim passenger
so let's cancel the passage which is
second accounts the stamp is that
seconded executive by Council stilts
thank you very much indeed again we we
have more than one nominee so we we have
to go into a vote does that wish to be
recorded
yes recorded vote nominated by Council
fluke and seconded by councilor still uh
stamp my apologies councilor stamp uh
slip of the throat as councilor
Bassinger's name was called first uh
again I'd like to put the councilor
passenger's name forward first uh Tara
could you call a roll call please
Ranger
foreign
[Music]
yep okay sorry continue please thank you
four
[Music]
abstain
four
[Music]
abstain
extra meal against
four
[Music]
against
four
cancer skills at Stone
perhaps the top
thing
right against
thank you Tara
and now we have the second nomination
which is for councilor stem
you don't need it
just wanted to make sure we'll do
everything in the in the spirit of
opening transversity therefore I do
declare that passenger is depths leader
of all district council councilor
passengers if you'd like to come to the
table please thank you
maybe you don't want to present report
to you
okay
okay yeah
because at the point of order yeah yeah
okay
as soon as I start speaking before the
point of order okay you gotta came with
councilor passenger yeah
all good all good lovely thank you
members we move on
foreign
I'd like to raise procedure rule four in
terms of the leader of the opposition
um and the despite the Constitution
stating that the opposition leader will
be the leader of the second largest
group
for the mission for the municipal year
23-24 that the leader of the
conservative group will be recognized as
the opposition leader I so moved I have
a second to please I don't believe that
exact Constitution correct I just need
to before we move forward I just need to
see the advice of the monitoring officer
please
foreign
the meeting for a comfort Breakers now 8
24 into seek the vice of the monitoring
officer so I'm going to reconvene the
meeting the meetings can be adjourned
from 8 24 we will reconvene 8 30. thank
you
foreign
thank you very much
thank you members I reconvening this
meeting thank you for your patience upon
cancer Center's request for a point of
order that's not a point of order upon
consultation with the monitoring office
and I would say to all members please
look at what a point of order actually
is it's a specific point on the agenda
which must be referenced or a point of
law
so we're going to reject that point of
order but you're more than welcome to
put in a written notice a motion a
second emotion and that can come to the
next meeting of council so thank you
very much
this will be to do with motions so I
think it will probably be to change
enough to him and I think it's procedure
rule four which deals with emotions so
for clarity yeah counselor siddle has
not put in Emotion in relation to the
Tory group being the uh the opposition
which is quite interesting because I
just put one into the monitoring officer
to committee Services uh
suggesting another group and I look
forward to debating that with you on the
13th of July thank you thank you very
much again that was that was um not
necessarily a point of order although it
was a point of information members just
based on the information it was called
about the leader of the opposition the
leader of the opposition is actually
jointly shared at this moment in time by
councilor Stills and councilor driver
um so that's where we are with regard to
that again if a written notice and
emotion comes forward until next meeting
that may change
so now we move on into our agenda item
number 11 which is appointment of
memberships of committees to the council
we moved to agenda item 11 the
appointments to memberships of the
council and that was circulated day and
found in this supplementary packs on
pages five to pages 12.
um before I call on on Mr Dodson to to
introduce this item I drew your
attention to recommendation three where
the council is required to make a
nomination to certain committees
confirmation of the appointments board
membership will be done following the
special meeting of committees once
chairman of the Committees have been
appointed could I ask Mr Dodson to
please present the report
thank you chairman
um yes this is for the the allocation of
seats on committees has set out in
section 3.6 of the report and for
members to to approve the nominations
that have been made there will be
additional nominations need to be made
to committees for those non-aligned
members of the the council and also as
um that the chairman has said the
appointments committee can't be
appointed we don't know the political
makeup of that until
um we get to that there's there's also
the joint standards committee
um because of the the position with the
political balance
there is one seat available that I
believe there are two
um two groups that are eligible for it
so Council will have to appoint to that
but the um the monitoring officer will
be able to clarify that um when we get
to that point Thank You chairman thank
you Mr Dodson members we have uh five
individual recommendations uh which I'm
chosen to move singly one at a time so
the recommendation the report is little
one is that the allocation of seats on
committees are set out in section 3.6
below be ratified
no counselor stamp please
chairman um looking at page six I'd like
to know where the mid digs are if you
look at it it says 3.3 conservative
group District support group liberal
Democrats I can't see any of the mid
digs listed on this paper
thank you James
you're quite correct cancer stamp
sorry I think the point is there's no
reference to or 3.3
um
we're looking at 3.3.3
I apologize chairman this this was
um obviously a late published paper due
to the putting all of the the
information together and that is an
oversight
okay so where do we move yeah
the modern independent group is listed
it's not the same name
group
not on this paper
it's conservative group District support
group liberal Democratic Democratic
group of my one there is an independence
group listed is that the agenda paper
that's published this afternoon on page
yeah I've got it here and it's not
listed
I have it here and it's not listed at
the moment so Mr Dodson Witnesses
Mr Welch is not listed either we need to
go by the published paper I've got I've
got a PDF copy
I need the names yeah okay okay so
that's Richard
just for a moment members I think we
have a workable a workable solution
MSD models
publishes published online publishing in
hard copy so we'll just just get this
advice from the officer and just yeah
put them in your stack and just be happy
in yeah
we're ready to go okay uh Mr Johnson was
just uh I call Mr Dodger just to speak
thank you thank you for clap for clarity
chairman I can confirm that the
political group
um has been received
um within all of the the guidance and
the the submissions
um and can confirm that the modern
independent group is made up of
councilor siddle councilor Bassinger
councilor Hughes counselor Stevens
councilor Shaughnessy and councilor
fittock
thank you Mrs Olson yeah members okay to
ratify that
yep okay that passes so we move on to uh
little two that the member nomination
set out in appendix a be approved
agreed members that's agreement thank
you
uh Council stamp sorry you may have to
put your hand up a bit higher because
you're behind uh councilor lay and you
do need to look around thank you um
could I just ask if this is the right
time chairman to ring up 3.7 of the
report because we're talking about if
you just bear with me a joint standards
committee
um are we are we voting on that on Mass
because I have I want to raise
um something on that
committee please chairman as a separate
item so if you want to pass all the
others that's fine but I would like to
speak to the council and the monitoring
officer on the makeup of this this
committee
um and I'd like to say even though we're
at opposite ends of the table now cats
are siddle and I put a motion in in June
2020. about the makeup of a joint
standards committee and we felt that it
should be equally balanced between and
this would be two two and two
um and I've had a chat I don't have to
say this a heated debate shall we say
with the monitoring officer today and I
would like to propose to save time and
experience of this meeting that we defer
the appointment of this committee so
this joint standards so the new members
can understand what motion Council
siddler and I put to this Council
because I've got the papers to back it
up the minutes the Motions there was
four motions put forward and they were
all approved at this Council thank you
very much indeed thank you
was correct we did do that that year
however it was just for that Municipal
year and it was it was cancer stamp
because across this fall through YouTube
why wasn't it then reassigned on the
political balances ever since at
statutory annuals no it wasn't okay it
was what what my ruling on that we will
defer
okay when it comes down to this
committee because of the the the the
conflict there we just need Clarity on
that so I'm proposing to defer that
if that helps you thank you thank you
very much indeed so with the exception
members of The Joint standards committee
that member approved nomination set out
in appendix a to be approved it's
approved by sin that's approved by a
Cent and keep little three that where
nominations have not been received the
council appoints members to these
committee positions is that agreed
percent let's agree thank you members
sorry Tara
are people who pointed those a little
bit later on in the agenda paper
we have to do that now
so nomination Department yeah councilor
settle
uh thank you chairman uh so for the
performance governance and audit
committee I would like to nominate
councilor Bell
secondary second if I cancel the
passenger thank you uh for the strategy
and resources committee I would like to
nominate councilor White seconded
and councilor lay
thank you members and then for the
overview and scrutiny committee I would
like to to nominate councilor siddle
Norman
seconded
she asked her
anybody asked her
yeah thank you chairman yes I have sent
an email to counselor siddle Norman
however I think because she is ill she
hasn't replied to my email and I didn't
have any other contact details for her
that that feels slightly wrong
um to me without confirmation that she
will accept so we nominated I think
because I cannot propose that that we
defer this one it's only until the 13th
of July when this Council meets again
and then whilst you're sending out good
wishes you could also say would you like
to be on over again scrutiny thank you
Jim
I think I think it's quite sure that's
why I have to do so yeah you can put it
to the vote yeah we need to put that to
the vote members so is
um
okay the finest there we go okay Council
series motions are they agreed members
but I said okay then we'll come back to
council flukers is that agreed but I
sent
thank you
I think maybe it's a good idea just to
for clarity each particular nomination
for each committee took for members to
say give a cent because the overview is
scrutiny one they've obviously heard
Adrian's view on it
um
do they want to at the pointer which you
can decline later on if she wants to but
she can be okay
present or Council Norman yeah yeah so
would you want to just go through each
one of them individually
um that he put forward through each
committee okay so again apologies
members um councilor Cyril could you be
kind enough just to go through the
nominations again and what we will do is
we'll take each nomination and we'll
vote on each nomination to go through
thank you
uh so to Performance governance and
audit I nominate councilor Bell
afraid
thank you that's been agreed
to strategy and resources I nominate
councilor White
agree but I sent thank you members to
strategy
yeah I'm going to do that one
thank you Tara
it's a strategy resources I nominate
councilor lay
counselor fluco you made a proposal
about cancer center Norman I think it
would be polite to ask councilor siddle
Norman if she wants this position so um
you know I'd have a proposed chairman
that we defer until the 13th it's only
two weeks
we've got the proposal and this
counselor siddle is going to withdraw
that
I know yeah so we do have that on the
table okay
what counselor said is treated as part
of the debate
[Music]
yeah that'd be easier thank you thank
you members thank you thank you chairman
uh So based on the discussion the
council has just had I will withdraw the
nomination for councilor siddle Norman
to overview institutes needed to be
referred to the next full council
meeting
watch indeed leader
okay thank you members for putting up
this is a rather complicated part of the
proceedings
so we move on to a gender writing little
four that members of 0.2 Town Parish
Council nominees to sit on the joint
standards committee
Tara thereafter is they're not on my
gender paper at the moment we'll work to
them later
or well that's the next on the list
isn't it
members I'm just going to adjourn for
two minutes the time is
8 47.
so I just had to seek advice from the
monitoring off from Mr Dodson so we go
on to appointing to the investigating
and disciplinary committee it's a
non-aligned member do I have a nominal
cancer
uh yeah I can I nominate councilor lay
seconded I seconded and agree thank you
very much we then move on to the
disciplinary investigating disciplinary
panel to have any nominations from a
non-aligned on this item
I'll nominate councilor white councilor
white uh 97 non-aligned
is it not to be no one online
my apologies yeah thank you very much
indeed is that second div members please
yeah thank you very much indeed uh it's
a great bar scent thank you members Now
we move back no we move on to the
appointments board which I'm going to
defer
um that is basically because now we have
two leaders and we have to work out the
political balance Council stamp
certainly
yeah we're deferring at this point
anyway
so we need to go back thank you
yeah but if you're deferring it anyway
anyway I'm just referring it to the next
meeting okay now we just move on to the
Joint standards committee where we need
to appoint Parish counselors
um two Parish Town councils appointed
from the following nominees councilor
stamp
we've deferred that appointments for the
whole of that committee that's why Miss
Board no no no JSC at this moment time
JSC I mean
the district members yeah
sorry sorry
but I wanted I wanted just for clarity
my deferral was for the eight District
members not for the town of Parish
councils chairman with all due respect
I'd like to defer the whole of it
thank you
um so I need to agree two Parish
councilors we have a list from the
nominating uh nominees which are Stephen
barbwell we've got Peter Allen Davey
Michael John Hall Lester Magnus and
Stephen Stratton
um so I believe we just go undertake a
vote okay
you know I would like to nominate
councilor Stephen Stratton
thanks again second did thank you
members has that agreed
well we can't do it at the moment no any
other nominations as a councilor Barbara
Steve barbell please cancer State
barbell is that seconded
okay any other nominations please
it was uh Peter Davey Peter Alan Davey
that was nominated by councilor
Bassinger
a second by Matt any other number
counselor suspensely I'd like to
nominate councilor Hall please oh is
that second did
thank you that's it and cassadorum
cancer Magnus
so
we'll go for a vote
that's right we need two out of five
yeah so what you do is
um I guess they have two votes each
member has two votes yeah so
um the one with the well I suppose what
we do is
I suppose you've got to deal with each
one separately yeah so to deal with the
first position and then the second
position and so it's about to sustaining
straight back isn't it if you put it to
the chamber the chamber votes and
whoever gets them at least gets dropped
off that's right so for the first
position
they're all
nominated for both positions so so it's
probably best to do it
probably best well until you could do it
for
the twos are both I suppose what you're
doing two left just ask members who you
voting for you 've got two well the job
is just two votes you've got two votes
because there's two positions well I
think we'll go through so you're just
complicated
okay yeah yeah I mean
yeah for the first
I think what you do is you just do them
one at a time yeah and then yeah one at
a time
the position which one yeah okay members
what because members thank you
and thank you for your patience um
because every every member's been
nominated so what we need to do is we
need to go through and vote on each
position individually okay so first
person we're gonna vote on is uh Stephen
barbwell well it's it's well it's each
seat isn't it yeah it's two seats so um
you know as they go around which one
they want okay for the first seat yeah
that's a good idea
yeah Miss bird
language of India any difference
that's exactly what the monitoring
offers just advised yeah I think that's
the way to go so we'll go around the
chamber members and if you could uh
nominate for the first position for the
first position the person who you wish
to nominate so we'll actually go around
the chamber
yeah if we could start with uh councilor
Morgan
uh that's the Magnus
sorry Tom we're going to record the vote
because that second did
yeah thank you very much
okay so we go again
one nominee okay so what we're going to
do we're going to do a recorded vote
Tara is going to call out the names and
then you need to vote for one counselor
initially please one nominee please
okay we're there
twister
Tara
first nomination is for Stephen Stratton
thank you
no no you choose who you wash from the
list yeah yeah you give a name thank you
yeah
Stephen Stratton
councilor Mike Hall
[Music]
Michael Hall
Stephen Stratton
Mr Stratton
Steve Stratton
cancer Jennings Michael Hall
Stephen barbwell
[Music]
councilor Morgan Lester Magnus
uh Stephen Stratton
Magnus
Steven Stratton
Stephen Stratton
Michael Hall
Michael Cole
councilor Swindle Michael Hall
Madness sorry Council white councilor
Bardwell
members please I can't hear
okay thank you members I declare that
Stephen Stratton is the first how can
Katara give them all again please slowly
four nine
Magnus for Stratton 10.
could dress me through the chair and
then I'll ask the monitoring officer to
respond
thank you chair through you chair thank
you I would say I believe that we should
do them individually so we've all voted
for our first choice and then we should
vote for our second choice otherwise
we're eliminating somebody which is
nobody's voted for it and yet we hadn't
a chance to vote for them
foreign
say that when you have an appointment
for more than two people and on the
first vote one of those doesn't get a
majority it's like in the American
election it was like in some of the
presidential elections a person with the
lowest number
it drops out okay so we have to go
through that and then that means daily
drops out so now you've got to go again
for the first seed still from the four
and they have another vote
members are just taking the thank you
Council Ambassador the monitoring
officers just explained that we have to
do it because it has to be done by a
majority so the person with the least
votes at this moment in time has to drop
out and then we vote again through you
chair if I may uh we we should have two
votes yes we'll go through this first
and then we go through again but that
that isn't at all clear because
initially we should have both we should
have used our two votes on the first
round and then we could have eliminated
yeah I think
as I yes
the rules say this there are two
positions
there are two seats
that means you have two votes
um each each appointment has to be dealt
with individually there are two
appointments
so although it sounds cumbersome
you have your first vote your first seat
and each one of you has one vote one
vote
if on that first vote there is no
majority
because all appointments have to be by
majority of those who vote
then the one with the least votes falls
out and you go again still on the first
the first uh position
and there are therefore going to be four
councilors left and you vote again now
as has been pointed out to be by Mr
Dodson of course the the
Mr Davey
didn't get any votes so that isn't going
to change so in that in that
in in view of that in view of that
um the two other ones that the lowest
are Mr Barnwell and Mr Magnus so they
they go out leaving a straight vote
between Mr Hall and
um for the first one for the first
position for the first position
um the reason is that when Mr I think Mr
Stratton if he's voted people might vote
they obviously for the second vote those
who voted for strata might vote for
somebody else they might all transfer
their votes to somebody who uh fell out
very early on in the first vote if you
see what I mean
okay so that's why it's complicated it's
got to be done that way so everyone has
a genuine two votes and every candidate
has two genuine opportunities unless
except for the one that's elected
pointed in the first seat so through
your chair I mean Mr quotes I do
understand that that is possibly an
American way of voting but surely the
most simplistic way of voting is for us
all to do one round with one vote first
and then go again and we can then maybe
transfer our vote as you say and Mr
Davey May in fact be the next one in
line well chairmanship uh procedure rule
eight sets out no procedure Rule 13 sets
out voting
on this particular matter
and
it says at table six
effectively what I've said that that's
the way it should be done
that may not be seen as the best way by
members but that is what the rules that
is the way the rules say it should be
done
so councilor Jennings please uh question
can we choose not to use our second vote
so you uh Jim you can abstain
okay Council Stevens
thank you chair
um okay so that may be what it says in
the rules and perhaps we should all be
thoroughly conversant with that but it
wasn't explained to us before we took
our first vote and I think some of us
might have voted rather more
strategically and I think we've wrecked
it now
um I think we ought to agree between us
how we're going to do this one and next
time we've got this situation if it's
explained properly then we'll all go
into it with our eyes open thank you
thank you councilor Burwood thank you
does it also therefore mean that
counselor Stratton is not going to be in
the next vote because he has been voted
for
correct
no no
okay
if members had voted for somebody who
had a majority in the if I may say if
there if one of the uh nominees had had
a majority in this vote that person
would then be appointed
to the position but because no one got a
majority and the rules say it's not the
person with the most votes that wins but
the person that obtains a majority
that's appointed we have to go through
this very painful process
so that leaves us where we have to that
means that that means my Reckoning for
what David didn't have any so that
wouldn't change anything so Bardwell and
Hall are out
oh sorry marble and Magnus about it
that's right so that leaves Hall and
is it Stratton Paul Stratton and Davey
no no Davey's hours
for the first position members have to
cast their vote again yeah
members I agree with you it's incredibly
cumbersome but that's what the rules say
so um at the moment uh Bardwell uh Davey
and Magnus are out so we go through the
same process again please Tara uh we
call on Michael John Hall and Stephen
Stratton so could you please vote either
way
we have to do it we have to do this
again afterwards second position
would you like me to explain it again
yeah please
um
very confused um yeah it's a council
floor could just let their monitoring
officer speak and then I'll come back to
you please thank you we're in a position
now where they're based on your voting
for the first appointment there are two
seats can I stress that there are two
seats dealing with seat one first
appointment
we're in a position now where
um the two people with the highest votes
were Hall and Stratton so members now
have to vote between those two if you
don't know either of them and prefer to
abstain you can abstain and it will be
the majority the the one that has the
highest votes that is appointed to the
first position okay the person that wins
is therefore appointed so coming to the
second seat because there are two seats
there will be four nominees and all are
back into the frame that didn't win for
the second position go and and we'll go
through the same process
is that clear members
asthma thank you very much members and
thank you for the monitoring officer to
help us understand this complexity okay
so we now go Tara for a recorded vote
please again just to give you a reminder
it's Stephen Stratton or Michael John
Hall please or Stein starting the
council Passenger please
Stephen Stratton please
Stephen Stratton
[Music]
cancer Michael
Hall
[Music]
Stratton
Mr Stratton
Hall yeah
abstain please Tara
Stratford
Council mortgage
Captain Morgan sorry councilor Neil
apologies Stratton
cancer perhaps
I'm saying
cap the shorter thing
it's absolutely Michael Hall that's the
coolest fantasy
Michael Hall
[Music]
Stephen Stratton
Michael Hall
Stratton please
uh councilor Hall
a chairman the results of that are 10
for Council hall 11 for chances
thank you very much
okay members thank you very much
therefore I confirmed the council
Stratton is appointed so Council
Stratton comes off the list members and
we move on to the second position again
all players are back in councilor
barbwell uh Davey Hall and Magnus
so members um I think we're familiar
with the position so again Tara if I
could ask you uh to do the Roll Call
Mr Davey
[Music]
councilor Hall
cancer driver Michael Hall
[Music]
has a Davey
Mr Davie
Davey
Michael Hall
I'm saying
Navy
[Music]
Michael Hall
Council Stevens Peter Davey
[Music]
Michael Hall
Council Thompson Davey
uh Mr councilor barbell
perfect
and two extensions thank you Tara
oh yeah
okay
members this was slightly easier because
councilor Davey has been elected with
the majority thank you very much indeed
members for that we now move on we're
still on agenda article 11 members and
we are a little five pleased that
members note the chairperson's job
description ahead of the appoint Mr
chairpersons of these committees in
appendix B that's for noting is that
noted
thank you members we now move on to
agenda item 12
um which is a German of meeting uh
members we will now adjourn this this
meeting at 9 16 P.M to allow the
following special meetings of the
council to take place performance
governance and audit committee strategy
and resources committee licensing
committee overview and scrutiny
committee
joint standards committee which we are
going to defer investigating and
disciplinary panel that's the
disciplinary committee District planning
committee Central area planning
committee Northwest area planning
committee South East area planning
committee members for each special
meeting the director of strategy
performance and governance will read out
the agreed membership for each committee
and as I said earlier on to assist our
clock and any members of the public that
are watching could you please stand when
your name is called Thank you so the
meeting is adjourned at 9 16.
oh sorry yeah apologies uh Mr Dodson
could you please call the names of
performance governance and all liquidity
councilor Bassinger
councilor Burwood councilor Miller
councilor Pratt councilor Shaughnessy
councilor spenceley councilor stamp
councilor stilts
councilor Thompson and councilor Bell
thank you very much
so I now call for nominations to
chairperson of the performance and
governance and audit committee for the
municipal year to May 2024. nominate
councilor Bell
members that agreed bar sent
that sent you'd like a vote a shower
hands or recorded
yeah shower hands uh could we put a show
of hands please those four
that's one two three four five six I
believe because just check that that's
six four those against
one against any abstentions two against
thank you two percent chance uh two
against any abstentions one two two
abstention no no you can't understand
you're running the committee two
extensions is that clear Tara
okay I now hand over to I declare that a
councilor
Bell is the chair of performance
governance order committee I hand over
to councilor Bell
thank you Mr chairman so can I ask for
nominations for vice chair
yeah nominate uh councilor Thompson
dead
any other nominations
okay then we'd take a vote so are we
happy with the show of hands
of course we don't I've still got
covered brain I do apologize thank you
councilor Thompson
is that the end so you can close the
meeting thank you very much I now um
close the meeting thank you everyone
okay we now we now move on uh for the
special meeting of strategy and
resources committee Mr Dodson could you
please call the names councilor bound
councilor driver councilor Durham
councilor fitick councilor fluka
councilor Jennings councilor siddle
counselor stamp
councilor Thompson
councilor white and councilor lay
thank you very much indeed Mr Dodson
members are now called for the
chairperson of strategy and resources
committee for the meaningful year to May
2024. nominate councilor Durham
is that secondary secular accounts of
Thompson
councilor fluka
I think we need to yeah
yes nominations at the moment so we've
got Kev councilor Durham and it has been
second
the app
okay remember so we have councilor
Durham as nominated as chair is that
agreed by sin
agreed show of hands please in that case
those four please so put your hands up
clicking out we count please one two
three
one two three four five six that's a six
four those against please show it's
to any abstentions
two abstentions thank you very much
okay it's done done okay
so councilor Durham
what
thank you very much uh chairman um so uh
yeah thank you very much uh committee
um I now seek nominations for the
position of Vice chair and strategorians
resources and from the chair I would
like to nominate councilor fitick
seconded
chairman
well
um are there any other nominations other
than councilor fitter
is that seconded
okay um so members
uh I think are just a straight
I'm sorry counselor for stamp
um okay
um so members could you indicate for
councilor fittock
foreign
resources and chairman I now close this
meeting of strategym resources at 9 22.
thank you
thank you councilor Durham
members I now are called for nominations
uh the committee for overview and
scrutiny committee Mr Dodson could I
please have the committee names please
councilor Hayward
counselor Hughes
councilor Morgan councilor Morley
councilor Neil
councilor spencerley councilor Stevens
councilor swindle
and counselor Witham
en and there's a vacancy for the for the
non-aligned member
okay so now what we need to do now look
for the nominations of the chairperson
of the overview in scrutiny committee
for the municipal year to May 2024 could
I please have nominations yes Mr
chairman I'd like to nominate myself
is that second did it second by
councilor Stevens any other nominations
okay therefore I declare that councilor
Morgan so we should put that to the vote
or is it there's no other nominations so
we might as yeah congratulations
councilor Morgan
thank you
members can I have a nomination for the
position of Vice chairman of the areas
I'd like to nominate councilor Paula
spensely
you're the chair I'm sorry yeah
uh is there any other nominations
but in that case obviously can't
suspensely Vice chair well done thank
you and the meeting the meeting is
closed
indeed at uh indeed the meeting is
closed to 9 25.
thank you members
um we now go move on to the Joint
standards committee please
not being constituted okay that's not
being constituted this evening thank you
we move on to the investigating and
disciplinary committee Mr Dodson please
because I guess
it's okay
have you not done licensing I'll go back
to that
councilor Neil
councilor Stevens councilor swindle
councilor Thompson
and councilor lay
thank you very much Mr Dodson I now call
for nomination for the chairpersons
please for the investigating
disciplinary committee for the miscipal
year to May 2024.
yes I'd like to nominate councilor
Thompson please
Thompson is that seconded please
hear any other nominations
okay I therefore declare that councilor
Thompson is the chair of the
investigation and disciplinary committee
councilor Thompson
Vice chairman of the indc and from the
chair I'd like to nominate cancer
Stevens is that second in please
sorry Council Swindle I'm sorry
somebody's microphones on
I wasn't aware that I was being
nominated and I'm not standing
sorry I apologized I was my ADHD brain
sorry
yes Council I also wasn't aware that I
was being nominated so
um I declined
yeah
so are you standing
okay
to be human
so nominations for vice chair so I
stepped down because I assumed that
councilor Swindle was aware and was
willing to do it but if she would prefer
not to then yes I will take some advice
can I renominate if that's necessary
is that seconded
[Music]
okay cheer
so I'm finished oh sorry yes um I've
declared Council Stevens to be the vice
chairman of the IDC that hasn't met
since 2011 thankfully um and closed a
special meeting thank you at 9 27. thank
you very much
We Now call for members of the licensing
committee members which I um negated on
the agenda paper Mr Dodson
councilor Bassinger councilor driver
councilor Durham councilor Haywood
councilor lay councilor Morgan councilor
spenceley councilor Stevens councilor
stilts and councilor Thompson
thank you so I know this is licensing
okay
if your name was called you need to
stand yeah
okay thank you very much indeed members
I now call for nominator the chairperson
of the licensing committee for the
municipal year to May 2024. Mr chairman
I nominate councilor Durham
any other nominations
verification okay because the licensing
committee is a pool of pool of 10 of
which they pick four of us and then when
we get to that hearing we choose a
chairman
okay thank you very much so thank you
very much indeed cancer so it's very
important to clarify those those points
so we have a chair called as councilor
Durham is that second dude
is that seconded
seconded by counts Stevens so I
announced accounts that Durham is the
chair of license committee Council
Durham thank you very much
um
members I know therefore call on
nominations for the vice chairman of
Licensing committee
I've forgotten him
oh and I shall dominate councilor Mrs
Thompson quite happy too like I did
are there any other nominations
no therefore I confirmed that counselor
Mrs Thompson is the vice chair of
Licensing committee and I close this
meeting at 9 30.
thank you Council Darren
District plan yeah now call for
um we're going to move on to the
denomination District planning committee
Mr Dodson please special meeting thank
you chairman this is all members
okay
so remember thank you thank you very
much
members okay I will now call for
nominations to chairperson of the
district planning committee for the
municipal year to May 2024 nominations
please
uh nominate councilor Lagan seconded
okay
I didn't but um being honest I I um I
served on that committee last year
um so yeah if is there any other
nominations
okay
councilor Fluker I'll indulge you on
that one because I'm an old chat with a
bad back thank you yeah so um and I know
other nominations
so therefore I declare that councilor
Lagan is the chair of the district
planning committee members may see okay
I'm gonna Now call for nominations for
vice chair of the district planning
committee
any other nominations
members therefore I declare that
councilor Pratt is the vice chair of
District planning essential area
District planning committee my apologies
been a very long night and therefore I
close this meeting at 9 30 pm thank you
members we now move on to Central area
planning committee Mr Dodson please
councilor Burwood councilor driver
councilor Jennings councilor Lagan
councilor lay councilor Miller councilor
Shaughnessy councilor spencerley
councilor spenceley councilor stilts
councilor swindle
are now called
nominate Council driver councilor driver
is that second dude
okay any other nominations please
are therefore announcer Council driver
is the chairman of the central area
planning committee as a driver
um can I call upon members who wish to
be the vice chair of the central
planning committee and I'm from the
chair called
um
um thank you doing any other any other
nominations or do we have a second thank
you any other nominations
in which case congratulations and I
closed the meeting at 9 31 thank you
Council the driver
we now move our members to North Western
area planning committee special meeting
Mr Dodson
councilor Durham councilor Hughes
councilor Morgan councilor Morley
councilor siddle councilor Stevens
councilor Thompson councilor white and
councilor whiffen
thank you I now call for nominations of
the chairperson of the Northwestern area
planning committee for the municipal
year to May 2024 do I have any
nominations please councilor Durham is
chair Senator councilor Morgan any other
nominations
with therefore no more nominations
councilor Darren please thank you very
much sure thank you very much members I
now call on Earth called the nominations
for the vice chair of Northwestern area
planning committee and from the chair I
nominate councilor Mrs Thompson seconded
or any other nominations
therefore confirm that councilor Mrs
Thompson is the vice chair of Northern
West Northwest area planning and closes
meeting at 9 33 I think
thank you councilor Darren we now move
on to the special meeting for South
Eastern Area planning committee and Mr
Dodson
councilor Bassinger councilor Bell
councilor bound councilor fittock
councilor fluka councilor Haywood
councilor layborn councilor Neil
councilor Pratt councilor siddle Norman
and councilor stamp
thank you very much indeed I I now call
for nominations to chairperson of the
southeast area planning committee
nominate councilor Bill Council the Bell
any other nominations seconded yeah I'd
like to nominate Council fluka
is that seconded
I'll second it that's it
thank you chairman but I'd just make it
clear that um you know I've watched very
closely tonight the voting and I won't
waste your time so I'll I'll Stand Down
and uh and and councilor Bell's already
talked about her allowances and the need
for them so I wish I wish her well and
putting food on the table very unfair
very glad that councilor is
foreign
we could take um nominations for vice
chair I'd like to nominate cancer
do I have a second seconded
um
thank you very much and I had my
microphone off I do apologize
members thank you very much indeed for
that
we now move on to item number 13 members
which is the resumption of business we
will now resume the business of this
extraordinary council meeting at 9 35.
members are agenda item 14 has been
deferred as early on in the evening we
move on to a Jetson item number 15 which
is appointments and representatives to
local government and outside bodies
we moved to a gender item 15 and a point
appointment of Representatives to local
government and outside bodies
yes
no we deferred that earlier thank you
Tara
yeah I'll just I'll just repeat that
thank you
um we moved to a gender item 15 which is
the appointments of Representatives to
local government outside bodies this was
circulated today members and it's found
on supplementary pack on pages 13 to 22.
uh Mr Dodson could you please uh
introduce the report
thank you chairman yes this is for the
appointment of Representatives to local
government and outside bodies as the
chairman says as detailed in appendix
one uh which has been nominated by the
respective political groups
um and this is for the endorsement of
those those places thank you thank you
Mr Dawson members we have three
recommendations to move on the report
I'm I'm proposing to take them as one
unless anybody objects so I will go for
a little one is that the appointment of
Representatives to local government
outside bodies as detailed in appendix
one nominated by the respective
political groups be agreed for the
municipal year to May 2024.
cancer driver uh yeah for the what's the
the tourism board at the moment I think
the uh
The Substitute is uh councilor Miller
and actually beforehand it was agreed
um that councilor Jennings would take
that substitute place if that is
agreeable okay I'll just run it by the
monitoring officer Mr Dalton is that
agreeable
drivers so the proposal for councilor
Jennings is has that been seconded
yes
cancer still secondary so so the little
two that Representatives that that were
represented is not approved to a point
to the outside body seats that's there
two and then little three that members
appoint as representatives to local
government and outside bodies are
responsible for sharing minutes of
meetings attended and to be stored
centrally on the mod.gov library as per
the details in section 3.3 of the report
below do I have a second of those
recommendations were executed by the
leader cancer settle members agreed we
buy sets agreed by ascent thank you
members we move on to agenda item 16
which is appointment of members to serve
a working groups we move to agenda item
16 and a point an appointment of members
to serve on working groups again this
was circulated today and found in the
supplementary pack on pages 23 to 30.
unlike Mr Dodson again for calling him
to present the report in summary
thank you chairman this this report is
for the appointment of members to serve
on working groups of the council I would
draw members attention that there have
been some updates to the the proposed
um operation of working groups following
the performance governance and audit
working group
um including the core and be set for
working groups of 50 of the membership
and the updates are set out amongst the
recommendations as well as members are
pointing to those working groups thank
you thank you Mr Dodson I have six
recommendations which again I would like
to read through and take it as one a
little one that members approve the
nominations for the working groups
provided by the respective political
groups in appendix one
fluka
uh did anybody wants to speak because
okay we'll take them individually so
councilor fluka
um
microphone cancer please thank you
um I spoke earlier on to the new
dovolution working group and I I know
chairman that there are four members in
addition to the leader of the council
leader the opposition and various
chairman
um but Gemini I also note that the four
members chairman it doesn't appear to be
anybody there from the
um from the modern support group which
um oh Council Council lag and I forget
your chairman I I wasn't sure if you
sorted but I do Wonder chairman in your
position the chairman
um whether or not you might consider
your position on that committee uh and
perhaps allow somebody else from your
illustrious group to take it on thank
you thank you councilor fluka
no I understand and I think I was
thinking of that I would actually step
back from that so it councilor stilts as
leader of that group of your nominee
uh thank you uh Mr chairman I'd like to
nominate councilor Fluker on that is
that seconded
all of those who substitute to you okay
that's fine and that's so we can just
carry on thank you that that's fine
thank you so we move uh on to a little
item two the three we've just done that
cancer Stevens for the sake of those of
us who couldn't hear councilor Fluker
could you explain what was just agreed
please we just couldn't hear councilor
fluka thank you
yeah on on the committee I've decided to
come off
and councilor fluka to come on because
of my position as chair I feel it's
better for that to be uh
uh better for the council for that to
occur
thank you councilor
okay so we're on to little three that
members appointed as the chairpersons of
working groups will provide a leadership
role and present back working group
recommendations to committee and the
council
little four as Mr Dodson has stated
earlier that a quorum be set for working
groups of 50 of the memberships
level five that substitutes for working
groups are allowed including non-allied
members who must notify directly as
working groups do not need to be
politically balanced
and little six that the makeup of the
member training and development working
group is changed to eight members of the
council as reflected in the political
group nominations as in appendix one
okay do I have a second because Council
fluka
microphone counselor
um
the the
with regards the quorums on on working
groups chairman and and I go back to
what I said we cancel them
to cancel the leader of the council
earlier on
um you know we've we've been at some
very very important working groups and
we've got eight or nine members on them
we've only had three members there and
we've had other members that aren't
allowed to vote really but we've always
listened to them and welcome whatever
they've said but if if some of those
meetings hadn't have gone on
reports wouldn't have gone to committee
or Council and we would have just been
log jammed and and this is so important
with the local development plan at
review or the the it's called something
else now but it's just so important and
I'm just really concerned that we could
tie ourselves up with this
um I'm not sure Mr Crouch I see your
heads down your classes are often you're
looking and maybe you'll tell me if we
can send substitutes but we've had the
situations before where we haven't had
substitutes then and it is this 50 I
think ties cancel enormously
I think um accounts of under little five
it actually defines that it substitutes
are allowed
so I think that would help balance the
the problem I I get that but it's really
it's been really really difficult to get
members to come to working I mean I
suspect a lot of members tonight are
realizing the enormously of what they've
taken on
um but tell me it can be really really
difficult for people to get to some of
these working group meetings and and
sending substitutes is fine but bear in
mind we changed the rules to allow any
member to go to any working group I
think
um and we still don't get anybody turn
up I I I would really
hate to Hob Tires over this 50 and I I
would say that we reduce it I I I'm
looking for some guidance from the
leader
um but you know maybe we should say
three members or something like that
because we don't want to miss out
because we get in a cycle of working
groups committees and Council and if you
suddenly get a working group that can't
meet because it's hogtied on membership
then that whole seven week cycle ceases
are you making a proposal that that's
changed Council of Luca chairman I am
making a proposal and and but I'm not
and I'm on a land chamber because I
managed to get one motion through
tonight but I I'm not sure what it
should be I mean I'm going to look
towards councilor diamond and other
experience on when you know whether it's
I can see councilor Thompson's like your
hands up and I'm sure she'll come up
with something but maybe it's three
members just so that we can and don't
forget and I think it's so the benefit
of new members working groups do not
make decisions they make recommendations
so they don't make decisions so you
don't miss out on anything but we need
to get that recommendation into a
committee so that the committee can
decide or cancel couldn't decide but
German I'll give way to councilor
Thompson thank you thank you councilor
Thompson and then councilor siddle
please thank you chairman um to my
surprise and probably his also I'm going
to speak in in to support councilor
Fluker who would he kindly support each
other for years
um because it you know you know I can't
help noting the working groups and not
decision making and yet we don't have a
quorum of on a 50 on anything else that
is decision making so why would we do it
on a working group that doesn't make
sense
um I would have thought three three
members of a working group would be
quite reasonable but it does also rather
indicate the pointlessness of trying to
avoid the whole Council to a working
group if we can't get if we can't get
half a dozen to turn up
um you know it's difficult the daytime
meetings and we now have substitutes
which if this passes is a big step
forward so um could I
suggest
second if if councilor Lucas saying
three but three members of the working
group and that passes the modern
monitoring offices gays then can I
second that thank you I just uh Mr
Dodson
it was just Just for information
chairman just to share I believe this
was a recommendation of the PGA working
group originally
I'm not sure when
uh thank you Chad uh I can fully
appreciate what council Fluker is saying
uh I was involved in some very important
working groups in the last year and it
was difficult to get even three people
to turn up to those working groups so
the fact that we now have the motion to
put forward substitutes I think will
help in terms of that yeah I agree with
councilor Thompson in terms of cap
committees our quora is three so
therefore I would put four Day
recommendation that core for working
groups is three counselors do I have a
second to please that's already been
okay
wasn't sure but yeah I support that
motion then
okay remember so we have a motion this
has been seconded on the table for the
amendment for a little four I can have a
vote on that that the court that sets
are three members if I show our hands
please
it seems to be unanimous
yeah that seems to be mostly unanimous
anybody against
no no abstentions so that's past Tara
thank you very much indeed so that was
we move on to the the recommendations as
a whole with that Amendment members as
members happy with the recommendations
that have been tabled this evening
agreed thank you members
okay we move on to agenda item 17. I
don't think I have to ask for an
extension of time members uh number 17
is questions to the leader of the
council in accordance with procedure
rule 17. are there any question
counselors Spencer uh Council sorry yes
I'm going to be really quick because I
know how much everybody wants to get now
but and I don't expect
a Clarity please
forward for the haybridge flood
alleviation reference group for this
year because it's not on here and I have
I have asked Mr Johnson and I haven't
heard so I would like to know what's
happening with that because that needs
to be
sorted out thank you
as a leader
thank you Council suspensely it is a
really really important matter for
heybridge and I think it's important
that we bring this back uh and we have
some kind of scheme a working group to
work on that liaising with our partners
in terms of those who are kind of
implement any schemes uh yeah I know
that great Totten causes a lot of the
the flooding in haybridge so my Parish
unfortunately award is responsible for
it so it is a wider thing both in the
Dengue as well so I think it's important
that we we have this focus and we we
have a working group that looks at those
things and and can Lobby in terms of
Partnerships and get Partnerships to
come to that working group hopefully
thank you later it satisfy cat
suspensely
Council well council did agree that we
would have the reference group at full
Council before the elections so I want
to see that happen please thank you
thank you Council specially any other
questions to the leader
councilor fluka
with these very important working groups
I think it's a really good idea to speak
to committee Services
um leader it's understood that you
recently stated that you're going to
review the 2324 budget which has a
shortfall of 830 000 and also the
medium-term financial strategy
um which has a shortfall of 1.2 million
pounds in 24 25 which means we're going
to have to spend 1.2 million pounds
worth of uh taxpayers money to pop up
the council
leader if this is correct can you
explain to council why you voted to
support the 2324 budget and the mtfs and
also did not support motion to council
for an Autumn budget in 2022 which which
if it gone through it would have reduced
those shortfalls dramatically which
would have improved the financial
position of the council now I would just
say leader that I am looking forward to
working with you on this strategy
resources uh working group I'm sure
we'll be looking at this but I would
like to hear what your thoughts are
because you know how important it is to
me this budget and trying to get it
right likewise the mtfs
thanks later
thank you thank you councilor feluca uh
it it's important to me as well yeah the
future of this council is is important
we are lucky in terms of the in terms of
comparison to other councils that we
still do have five million pounds of
Reserves
that was recently produced that we have
five million pounds of reserves so we
are in a good position however you are
correct that if we don't look at how we
spend our money and the way that we
allocate our money in a couple of years
time we'll be below our minimum reserves
we don't really want that to happen
what I feel that we need in terms of the
council is to ensure that our strategy
reflects
how we our expenditure reflects how we
look at our services and one of the
things I'm interested to hear from is
the LGA Finance peer review so we are
waiting for that report to come
and I think that report will really help
us in terms of
ensuring that we set our strategy and
connect that strategy to our finances
because not enough of that has been done
in the past
uh so it's tying those two things
together we can't just cut the cutting
sake one of the things we've got to look
at is how we share services with other
local authorities if we have no services
to share
we won't be able to work with other
local authorities so yes you're right
this is important and what I hope will
happen in in the very near future is
that we change the finance working group
into a finance board that is has a
cross-section of all groups on the
council that are represented on that and
that's something I'd really like to see
happen
so that would then beef up and look at
connecting our finance into strategy
thank you very much thank you Lita
members any other questions uh councilor
Stan please chairman I've got one um a
resident actually asked me to ask this
question
um
does the
councilor Sid all have any intention of
joining the concert concert conservative
party and leaving the big digs thank you
Peter well as you know I I got I was
elected as a as a conservative uh member
to this Council and unfortunately
through different things happening
during the during my first few years of
being a counselor I felt that my
relationship at that particular point
was untenable with the conservative
party and that's when I became an
independent however I have no intention
of joining the concert they probably
wouldn't want me anyway uh yeah yeah let
alone me joining them but the key thing
about what we need to do at this council
is to ensure that we work together
ensure that we work and that's what
we've seen tonight in terms of how
things are voted and way things are
voted we have voted across parted we
have a supported across parties and
that's what we need to do at a local
level
having the focus on our district and
have a focus on our residents is the
most important thing so I can
categorically say I'm sorry our time and
I won't be joining you uh however I look
forward to working with the
conservatives and the liberal Democrats
and the DSG in terms of and the
non-aligned yeah in in terms of
administering this Council and working
ensuring that this Council delivers for
the district
thank you leader that's our 15 minutes
of leaders questions so we move on to
agenda item 17 business by reason of
special circumstances considered by the
chairperson to be our counselors still
it's my apologies
um thank you the question for the leader
was that at the next meeting you will
have to do a leader statement are you
going to share it with the leaders of
the other parties beforehand
later
it will be shared by with the other
leaders of the of the parties because
we are in a coalition
however we are working informally
with other political groups to ensure
that we administer this Council in the
right way so I won't be making any
statements I'm not I won't be making any
any thing without the approval
of other groups that we're working with
and that's the crucial thing
thank you thank you councils thank you
members um
in my haste to move number 17 but the
business by reason of special circus is
considered by the chairperson to be
urgent there is none apart from the fact
that I would like to thank everybody
this evening for their patience and I
want to extend a very very gracious
thank you to the officers for their
support and guidance as well councilor
stem I'd like to also thank you it's
your first one and it was pretty tricky
but it did pretty damn well thank you
very much indeed
so members um we move on to closure of
the meeting thank you for your
contribution this evening I now draw
this meeting to a close at 9 59 oh just
in time
um members as this is now closed you're
advised not to enter into any further
discussion please leave the meeting
promptly and drive home or walk home
safely thank you